oui je je je vous remercie de le
mentionner effectivement on nous a
signalé à plusieurs endroits ce qui
pourrait s'apparenter à des ratonnades
contre des militants qui des pardon des
supporters de l'équipe marocaine et moi
je le dis depuis plusieurs jours je suis
très inquiète des groupuscules d'extrême
droite dans notre pays qui sont
maintenant en toute impunité vous avez
dans mon groupe parlementaire alors que
nous faisons une tournée des facs
pendant depuis plusieurs mois avec à
l'Université de Bordeaux 400 à 500
jeunes qui étaient dans une université
avec Carlos Martins bilongo
une vingtaine d'insultes d'individus
cagoulés et armée de barres de fer qui
sont arrivés et ce n'est que grâce à
notre service d'ordre qu'ils n'ont pas
pu rentrer le même soir la suppléante de
Sylvain carrière le député de l'Hérault
qui elle est reconnu en sortant d'un bar
trois individus cagoulés là aussi des
barres de fer qui est la course avec
deux autres militants et partout où
Carlos Martins bilongova cette phrase du
de Fournas qui est répété sur des
affiches sur le bar où il doit se rendre
à Toulouse avec marqué qu'il retourne en
Afrique je suis inquiète de d'un passage
à l'acte et de la généralisation le
ministre de l'Intérieur sur vous avez
interpellé le ministre de l'Intérieur
là-dessus ou vous pensez qu'il ne
l'avons pas à la hauteur des enjeux on
va je vais laisser le ministère du temps
au ministère pour pouvoir le faire je
vais pas directement mais je disais
quand même au ministre lui-même que
j'étais étonné que lorsque vous avez 24
individus cagoulés et armés donc qui ont
deux délits à la fois le visage
dissimulé plus port d'armes de catégorie
D que les policiers quand ils arrivent
une demi-heure après
ne procède à aucune arrestation ni même
à aucun contrôle d'identité je le dis
parce que ça m'inquiète en fait ce qui
est en train de se passer et moi j'ai
interpellé monsieur Darmanin qui a dit
qu'il prenait au sérieux donc j'attends
de voir ce qui va se passer mais nous
avons déjà il y a trois ans fait une
commission d'enquête sur la question des
groupuscules d'extrême droite certains
sont en train de se reformer et je vous
le dis il y a alerte dans ce pays pour
dissoudre une partie de ces bandes qui
sont et aujourd'hui violentes et neuses
on passe un
[Musique]